um did you see that I think it was a
Steve Carell movie Abracadabra yeah with
Jim Carrey and Steve Carell it was dude
it was really funny it was ahead of
residency in Vegas Jim Carrey was like a
parody of uh Chris Angel it was a yeah
Jim Carrey was a parody of uh of Chris
Angel right and Steve Carell was a
parody of David Copperfield Yeah were
you in that movie no but I saw it I
remember seeing it they didn't have
anybody I didn't think they had a they
didn't have a Carrot Top Cameo that's
fine that's [ __ ] I mean is that how
like a residency is like like do you
have a penthouse on the top floor of the
hotel and then you go down and do shows
or it's kind of like you do your own
thing no is Wayne new people always
think that though yeah
the old days and that thing and you
sweets this broads and Coke and no
there's there's ESPN at home
and that's it and heat up some food and
since you started doing a residency like
you kind of just been here and when I
first got the room at the Luxor I was up
at the top of the you know there was a
big Suite up there at the top what
happens up there oh well
horribleness because you have to take
the side elevator because like this up
the side it's called an inclinator
really yeah so it moves sideways so
with your when you're when you're drunk
you don't feel a thing When You're Sober
like what the [ __ ] and so you go and you
shop at every floor and everybody you
know the time you get to your room
everyone's in the house
yeah the inclinator and so it was yeah
it was horrible living up there it's you
know you have to just live with the you
know
right and so uh yeah you get you know
now you get on and go home and you're
living on my life and yeah you're at the
top floor of that
in that little light you sit that's you
my car was sleeping because the [ __ ]
lights
no it's right below it I remember when
the Luxor was built it was in the 90s
yeah like um and it was it was maybe it
was like the first Billion Dollar Casino
hours to create some staggering number
and I remember thinking God it seems
that it seems kind of evident that the
odds are not actually in the favor of
the gamblers
you know because like how are they
building have each new casino bigger and
more like yeah they made their money
back that way like they're made they're
they're
they seem to be like trying their best
to let you know because everything that
they put up is just more fantastic and
expensive than the last and nobody gets
the message
nobody gets the message where's this
money coming from everybody comes to
Vegas they're just making donations
it's coming from you are you do you
gamble much or no did you when you first
got here never yeah not really never
it's weird never I'm
it's weird energy and I don't know the I
don't know the the math and the numbers
and I know like you said you know look
at the size of your house look at the
size 16 and someone's getting [ __ ] you
know yeah so I don't know like smoke and
I don't like a lot of crowds yeah so I
just don't I don't that's not my thing
right I I worked on cruise ships I
shouldn't say that I love that I love it
I worked on cruise ships as a circus
clown before you know the the TV stuff
started and um
the cruise ship director they would have
an orientation show in the first night
of the week-long cruise and at the end
of the show it says to everybody now
have a have a great time make sure you
stop in the casino make a donation and
uh like it it was it was good good fun
and uh
and I just think it's it's so perplexing
to me and I think that you don't have to
worry about saying oh I love Vegas
because like like gambling is just a
real thing you know like here in Vegas I
I remember like learning a lot of these
uh dealers like the Blackjack like
whatever you know like they're running
the table when their shift ends a lot of
them just hop over to the other side of
the table
you would think that these people
working in the casino would be most uh
educated about like
about what's going on yeah what's going
on the inside they would have the
Insight right like to however they're so
close to it they're so educated they
know what's going on they get done work
with how this works and then they just
go to the other side of the table and
make a donation they donate everything
that's nothing I hated about too I said
never but the two or three times ever
did you know I'm sitting there and I'm
I'm looking at it whatever I don't know
I don't know what to do it's like you
know look at the dealer and she's like
so I'm like like hit or and again
there's so much pressure right so I just
follow her and nine times out of ten I
would I would win just usually then they
get it wrong too sometimes but people
would get so mad you just ruined like
I'd go you know hit me and the guy she's
like you just [ __ ] ruined the whole
thing and I said wow he's like and he
just get mad and leave and I said what
did I do said you did nothing you're
supposed to hit that I said but why do
you just [ __ ] explain me
was I not supposed to hit it she goes no
you're supposed to hit it he's got
pissed that he didn't he took his card
his card is my goddamn car because I got
the card yeah yeah like I said I don't
know the table I probably did [ __ ] up
the game no but that's it like the
gamblers are just so weird superstitious
it's like I've tried to play like Texas
Hold'em at a Commerce Casino and then
you go and sit down and people are
pissed at you like hit they're like dude
you're not what are you doing right
nobody has any [ __ ] idea what they're
doing you know like it's all luck yeah
and that's the thing that like like what
alcoholic like will justify as like
drinking like a gambler is like dude
there's uh you know there's strategy
involved in this
I mean you get the poker championships
right poker like the like there's people
who are like good at it right yeah
yeah that's a valid argument I have
nothing to rebute that with but yeah I
was one of the two I mean the same thing
I mean these people say they're really
good at it but are they or is it just
luck is it I I don't know because
there's always the Championships in the
same guy like Jesus and those other guys
they're always they're always in the
Phil Hellmuth or like
famous for making a bunch of money
playing poker and they like beat out
like 25 000 people of like you know to
get to that table so it's like I
remember when uh when I was uh 20 years
old I had just gotten out of my first
rehab
and uh I was living with a guy worked
with in a restaurant
and they would have like poker night and
and I'd be trying to party and like you
know like
because I was you know because you're a
drinker
degenerate right you know like in the
rehab didn't stick you know so I was
trying to do my thing and get loaded and
hammered and these guys were playing
poker like all night until the sun came
up and I was just like when are you guys
gonna stop with this poker and party
with me you know this is so annoying
like stop it with the boat there's like
12 hours after he got out of rehab
right and uh and I just remember like
that feeling that there was a a a really
genuinely addictive quality of this they
could not stop the sun's coming up it
was like they were on cocaine yeah they
were just playing poker pot calling the
kettle bleed like you just gotta be like
you [ __ ] you guys have a problem dude
right right right
I get it but uh but but they're just
like so that was one of the one of the
you know did I just said gambling always
just weirded me out and
my mother's father my my maternal
grandfather
uh was like during World War II I think
it was he uh
sold bootleg gasoline and in uh Canada
because because of the war they had
rations you could only buy so much
gasoline even if you were rich but he
was this kind of a shady character who
wouldn't sell a bootleg gasoline beyond
the rations you could get as much as you
wanted from him and that made him quite
a wealthy man he uh like had a boat he
walked around notoriously with like a
big wad of cash and it's very like
flashy kind of a shady character
alcoholic and um got wealthy but he had
a gambling problem and all this money
that he made it's telling bootleg
gasoline he gambled it away and then he
shot his shot himself suicide
gunshot to the head with some uh
got a gun I got gunshot that you know
and then so like and that happened when
I was I mean I think I was a newborn
baby I never even met the guy I don't
know but but that was another like
there's all these things with gambling
like I've never been into it yeah never
played a bet in my life except when I
got uh paid a fairly obnoxious amount of
money to uh promote
I have some gambling app right yeah then
and I did I did that it's interesting
your grandfather shot himself in the
head they said when men can commit
suicide they'll shoot their brains out
and then when women do it they'll either
like take pills or shoot themselves in
the heart because they don't want
anybody messing up their face right
isn't that a weird stat it's really
crazy man it's true guys are just like
[ __ ] it it's called Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of Amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on Amazon and
buy Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
cheers